Connors / McEnroe
Duel de hautes volées
L'Amérique des années 50.
C'est celle d'Elvis où grandi Mohamed Ali,
et qui verra bientôt mourir Kennedy.
Mais Connors et McEnroe restent en fait
dans deux Amériques.
Le cœur des États-Unis, East Saint Louis,
Illinois pour Jimmy en 1952.
Papa Connors tient le péage du pont
qui enjambe le Mississippi.
New York et le Queens pour John
qui arrive sept ans plus tard.
Le père McEnroe est un grand avocat
d'affaires à deux pas de Central Park.
- Connors, c'est vraiment un type
de l'Amérique profonde,
qui vient d'un milieu assez modeste,
et qui se conduit
d'une manière assez grossière,
en général et en particulier.
- Sa famille était une famille,
pas pauvre,
ce serait une erreur de la décrire comme ça,
mais qui n'était pas une famille cultivée,
et sans doute beaucoup plus intéressée
par les matchs de baseball,
que par l'avenir du monde.
Connors, c'est le plus Américain
des Américains.
À l'époque, les Américains étaient un
petit peu ignorants du reste du monde car,
avant d'avoir ces soucis du Vietnam,
était quand même le pays dominant du monde,
et je pense que Connor se foutait de ce qu'on
pensait de lui à l'extérieur des frontières.
- Va te faire foutre !
Tu es vraiment un petit trou du c** !
- McEnroe, c'est plus compliqué,
c'est un vrai New-Yorkais.
Avec le côté "sale gosse" New-Yorkais,
l'accent New-Yorkais très marqué.
- Il faut te le dire en quelle langue ?
Assieds-toi !
Mais au fond,
c'est un enfant de bonne famille.
Il se laisse aller parce qu'il est mal élevé.
On l'appelle le "sale gamin",
mais il est plus chic
dans toute sa manière d'être.
- Il a fait l'université de Stanford.
En plus, je pense qu'il a toujours été séduit,
par les arts et par le milieu artistique.
Donc c'est quelqu'un qui était
beaucoup plus ouvert sur le monde,
que ne pouvait l'être un Jimmy Connors.
Derrière ce duel de champions
se cachent des femmes à poigne.
Deux mamans.
Kate McEnroe, l'infirmière discrète
mais ultra-exigeante,
elle imagine son fils dentiste
et certainement pas sportif de haut niveau.
- C'est sa maman qui l'a toujours poussé.
Kate McEnroe n'était jamais satisfaite
de ses résultats scolaires.
S'il était deuxième...
"Pourquoi tu n'es pas premier ?"
C'est elle qui lui a inculqué
ce goût de la compétition.
Exactement comme chez les Connors.
Sauf que chez les Connors,
ce n'est pas une mais deux femmes,
qui vont léguer cette confiance
à toute épreuve à leur champion.
Les petits mots d'encouragement
dans les chaussettes, c'est la grand-mère.
Les hurlements "Jimbo" sur le bord du court,
c'est Gloria, la maman, prof de tennis.
- Sa mère lui a toujours décrit
le tennis comme un combat de boxe.
Il y a des gros parallèles entre les 2.
Le tennis, c'est une boxe mentale.
On ne se porte pas de coups physiques,
mais on se porte des coups au moral.
Elle a tout fait pour que
son fils devienne un champion,
en lui inculquant dès le départ le jeu,
elle a vu qu'il était doué.
et puis on lui inculquant ce goût du combat.
Le premier duel a pour décor Wimbledon.
Jardin de Jimmy Connors.
À 25 ans, Jimbo est le patron des courts.
Six ans déjà qu'il enthousiasme
la planète tennis.
En 1977, John McEnroe n'est que lycéen
lorsqu'il se dresse face à lui,
pour la demi-finale.
18 ans à peine.
Totalement inconnu.
Et dans les vestiaires,
Connors se charge de l'accueillir.
- Il n'a pas dit un mot à John.
Jimmy l'a complètement
ignoré dans le vestiaire.
"La première fois que j'ai posé
les yeux sur McEnroe,
c'était dans le vestiaire
des hommes à Wimbledon."
Quelques minutes avant
d'entrer sur le Central.
Il me faisait penser aux Pittsbury Doughboy
avec un bandeau sur la tête.
Je me suis dit Comment diable
a-t-il pu se qualifier ?
C'était clair, je n'allais rien lui céder.
Et au contraire lui rentrer dedans."
- John ne l'avait jamais vu et Jimmy
ne lui a pas adressé la parole.
John, ça l'a intimidé. Jimmy a essayé
de s'imposer en étant arrogant.
"Il s'est avancé vers moi pour se présenter.
Moi, j'ai attrapé mon sac, mes raquettes
et j'ai passé mon chemin.
Ni sourire, ni bonjour, ni poignée de main,
comme s'il n'existait pas."
- Évidemment, ça ne lui a pas plu.
Je n'irais pas jusqu'à dire
qu'il était en colère.
Il a quand même gagné un set,
ce n'est pas si mal.
- Ce n'était pas le genre à lui faire
un câlin ou à lui donner l'heure.
Connors a dû le voir arriver
comme une menace.
Ce premier duel sur le gazon anglais,
Connors le gagne.
Mais les deux joueurs prennent date,
et le monde du tennis comprend
tout de suite qu'entre ces deux là,
on ne va guère s'ennuyer.
- Ces deux joueurs
sont des Bulldogs redoutables.
Avec des origines très différentes.
Qui veulent gagner, donner le meilleur
et divertir le public.
Et ils y sont vraiment arrivés.
Chacun à leur manière.
- Connors, très énervé là.
Entre coups de gueule et coups de génie,
c'est le début de 14 années d'un duel
qui va révolutionner le tennis américain.
- Mon frère était un génie torturé
sur le court.
Il a amené tellement de passion au tennis,
tellement de flair.
- C'était Mc le magicien,
une sorte de génie du tennis.
On ne comprenait pas comment il jouait.
On avait l'impression quand il allait à la volée,
qu'il attirait la balle vers lui,
les joueurs avaient un mal fou,
à deviner ce qu'il allait faire.
- Ce n'était pas un grand athlète,
mais il était tellement rapide.
Ils étaient toujours replacés avant
même que vous ayez frappé la balle.
- D'un côté le McEnroe,
technicien, l'intelligence,
un peu comme un Mohamed Ali de l'époque.
Et puis de l'autre côté, Connors,
c'était plus le Tyson qui cherchait
tout le temps le chaos,
à vouloir frapper systématiquement
sur tout ce qui bougeait.
- Jimmy Connors, c'était
un combattant des rues.
C'est le premier joueur de sa génération
qui a amené cette mentalité sur le court.
Il aimait le chaos.
- C'était le compétiteur ultime.
Il ne vous laissez jamais respirer.
Il était sur vous sans arrêt.
Alors, imaginez ce Connors là,
déboulant avec ses sales manières,
dans les Country club du début des années 70.
Comme un chien dans un jeu de quilles
pour ces clubs très selects,
où la haute société toute de blanc vêtue,
règne sans partage sur le tennis.
Ici, notamment à Forest Hill.
Le club huppé de New York accueille
à l'époque l'US Open.
- C'était calme. On applaudissait.
On pouvait même siffler si on n'était pas
d'accord avec une annonce de l'arbitre.
Jimmy Connors est arrivé avec ses gestes
plutôt suggestifs, un peu coquin sur le court.
Et nous, on faisait...
C'était choquant.
Choquer le monde des Country Club,
les bourgeois, je pense,
ça a dû être un
des grands plaisirs de Connors.
Connors avait une tendance...
Difficile à réfréner,
à toucher ces organes virils,
à n'importe quel moment, que ce soit
pour signifier qu'il avait de la chance,
que l'autre avait de la chance...
C'était sans arrêt.
Toute sa gestuelle était
à la limite de l'obscénité.
- Est-ce que j'ai aimé voir Connors
jeter sa raquette ?
Je crois bien que oui !
Chacun a sa façon de se rebeller.
À chacun sa bête noire.
Pour l'un, c'est "l'establishment".
Pour l'autre,
ces fichues trajectoires de balle.
- McEnroe voulait jouer le match parfait.
Il voulait gagner 6-0, 6-0, 6-0,
en ne perdant aucun point.
C'était ça son objectif chaque fois
qu'il entrait sur un court.
Et il n'était pas heureux tant qu'il
n'y arrivait pas. C'était un perfectionniste.
Et quand le cogneur se frotte
aux perfectionnistes,
qu'il cherche à le broyer,
quand l'autre vise le sommet de son art.
- Oui, il y a faute Monsieur McEnroe !
Forcément, ça explose.
- Comment pouvez-vous être sûr d'ici ?
- Alors écoute...
J'en ai marre que tu te comportes
comme un gamin.
Tu as vraiment l'âge mental
de mon fils de 5 ans.
- Maintenant tu te tais !
- Ça va mal !
Et Madame applaudit.
- McEnroe et Connors se détestaient.
Il y avait vraiment un monde culturel...
Quand ils jouaient, c'était la guerre.
Ça faisait des étincelles.
On sentait une sorte de haine.
Partout où ils se croisent, Mac et Jimbo
ont le bon goût de se détester.
Leur terrain de jeu favori,
c'est New York, Flushing Meadows,
dans des duels en nocturne
totalement survoltés.
Le plus épique de tous,
cette demi-finale de 1980.
Le père et le petit frère
sont là, côté McEnroe.
- Ils ont quitté le court à 00h15.
Match interminable.
Combat acharné.
- Je me souviens de l'intensité.
À l'époque, la loge réservée aux familles,
était pratiquement sur le court.
Connors se retournait tout le temps
pour parler à sa loge,
ou même de notre côté à nous
pour chuchoter des trucs.
C'était sa façon d'être.
John était davantage concentré
sur le jeu lui-même.
La bataille tourne d'abord à l'avantage
de John qui remporte la première manche.
Mais la machine Mac se dérègle.
Connors avale 11 jeux d'affilée.
Mac devient fou.
- Prévenez-moi quand vous verrez
une bonne balle !
Que voulez-vous monsieur "je ne sais quoi" ?
Monsieur l'incompétent !
- À un moment dans ce match là,
sur une balle de debreak,
McEnroe perd le point, explose littéralement,
jette sa raquette.
La raquette passe de l'autre côté
du terrain, va vers Connors.
Out et Swan at the Mark.
- Jimmy l'a ramassé.
J'ai cru que ça allait mal tourner
quand il a fait mine de la lui lancer.
Et en fait, il s'est approché et l'a rendu
à John alors qu'il rejoignait sa chaise.
À ce moment-là du match,
Connors exaspéré par McEnroe,
parce qu'il a tendance à le prendre
pour un gamin intenable.
Connaissant un peu Connors, il a dû dire :
"Tiens, reprends ton jouet."
Connors devait saliver.
Il devait y avoir un plaisir sublime,
chez Connors de pouvoir jeter
la raquette à McEnroe comme ça,
d'avoir rendu fou Mcenroe,
je pense que ce sont des moments...
Aujourd'hui, McEnroe doit se sentir humilié
de ce qui s'est passé pendant cet instant.
Le plaisir est de courte durée
pour Jimmy Connors,
qui finira par s'incliner au tie-break
dans la cinquième manche.
La poignée de main est à l'image
de leur relation : glaciale.
C'est vraiment cette longue,
dure rivalité Connors-McEnroe,
qui fait du tennis aux Etats-Unis
un sport populaire.
C'est vraiment à ce moment là
que ça se passe.
Avant, ce sont toujours
les grands sports américains,
le baseball, le football
et le basket qui dominent.
Mais ce qui se passe sur le court, quand
il y a Connors et McEnroe qui jouent,
ça en fait un sport de gladiateurs,
un sport pas très bien élevé,
un sport que les gens peuvent regarder,
comme ils regardent un match de foot
entre copains avec une bière,
en poussant des hurlements.
C'est le moment où beaucoup d'enfants
vont se mettre à jouer au tennis.
Et le moment aussi où beaucoup
de sponsors vont rentrer dans l'arène,
avec des contrats publicitaires
comme on en avait jamais vu auparavant.
La période Connors-McEnroe, est celle de la
plus grande popularité du tennis aux Etats-Unis.
Ce n'est pas la même chose aujourd'hui.
Cette euphorie, ce public en délire,
pousse les organisateurs de tournois
à sortir des clubs,
où ils sont désormais à l'étroit.
À la fin des années 70, un stade immense
est construit à New York,
Flushing Meadows, 18 000 places.
Le tennis change de peau
et en même temps d'esprit.
- Une partie du public vient pour
se divertir et Jimmy le sait.
Tout le monde sait que McEnroe
est susceptible de sortir.
"Vous n'êtes pas sérieux ?"
C'est son slogan.
D'ailleurs, s'il ne le fait pas,
ils repartent déçus. Et Jimmy, c'est pareil.
Les gens viennent voir un show.
Ils considèrent qu'on leur doit un spectacle,
et pas seulement un match.
Et forcément, la télé s'empare
aussi de ce show.
Dans la foulée de la construction du stade,
la première chaîne 100% sport,
voit le jour en 1979.
ESPN diffuse tous les matchs
sans attendre les finales.
Désormais un Connors-Mcenroe
se savoure aussi dans son canapé.
Les organisateurs de tennis comprennent très
vite que la télé va les rendre populaires,
alors que des sports ont résisté
à l'arrivée de la télé,
Le foot ne voulez pas être retransmis
car moins de spectateurs dans les stades.
D'un coup, les joueurs
de tennis sont devenus des idoles,
vous les aviez en gros plan dans votre salle
à manger, dans votre salon pendant des heures.
Il y a plus de gros plans de McEnroe-Connors
à cette époque là que de n'importe quel acteur.
Donc ces gens vous sont familiers,
et comme en plus, ils expriment
des sentiments extrêmement forts,
de colère, de rage, de douleur,
de choses comme ça,
ils deviennent des idoles,
mais mécaniquement.
Des idoles vers qui l'argent afflue.
Maillots, shorts, chaussures.
Beaucoup d'équipements entiers
commencent à draguer les champions.
Connors encaisse les dollars
des uns ou des autres,
se fâche avec une marque,
signe avec une autre.
Fidèle à une seule chose :
sa raquette en métal, sa Wilson T2000.
Même lorsqu'elle n'est plus fabriquée,
un vrai dinosaure, impossible à corder.
Un jour, Connors me donne
quelques raquettes à faire.
Je corde et j'en casse
autant que j'en fais.
Je me fais parfois mal aux mains parce que
quand la corde pète, on est à 25, 26 kilos.
Il y a quand même énormément d'efforts.
Je lui dis Jim, je n'ai pas fini
parce que ça casse tout le temps.
"Quand est-ce que tu changes de raquette ?"
Avec son vocabulaire à part,
il me dit : "Tu changes ta main, c**** !"
Sur le moment...
Il m'a traité un peu de...
Puis...
Et il a raison, la raquette,
c'est sa main.
Connors a, quasiment toute sa carrière,
joué avec la même raquette,
et il se dit et je pense
que c'est vrai qu'en fait,
Connors n'a jamais été payé vraiment
pour jouer avec cette raquette,
parce que probablement que Wilson savait
qu'il n'était pas capable de jouer,
avec une autre raquette qu'avec
cette raquette qui lui allait à merveille.
C'était quelqu'un qui,
sur le plan des contrats,
était probablement moins
spectaculaire qu'un McEnroe.
Et puis c'était le début aussi.
Ce sont les premiers gros contrats.
C'était McEnroe, Borg,
gros pour l'époque.
En cette fin des années 70,
McEnroe est à l'origine,
de l'un des plus retentissants
succès du marketing sportif.
John, le "sale gosse"
écrit l'histoire de Nike.
Pour la première fois, une star
du tennis vend son image de rebelle,
à un marchand de chaussures,
et à son fondateur, Phil Knight.
- Ils sont venus le voir jouer.
Phil Knight, le président de Nike,
a vu John dans un tournoi junior à Dallas.
Et il a dit à ses hommes :
"Faites signer ce garçon."
C'est ce qu'on a fait.
Et John n'a jamais quitté Nike depuis.
McEnroe était le prototype parfait pour
lui parce qu'il pouvait l'utiliser.
Il ne laissait pas les gens indifférents.
Il râlait, cassait des raquettes.
Tout ça a un prix et tout ça est formidable.
Phil Knight est rentré dans ce trip là
et il a dit : "C'est vraiment lui que je veux."
"Il a 18 ans, mais je suis sûr qu'il a
du potentiel. Je suis sûr qu'il va être fort.
Donc je vais faire
ma carrière autour de lui."
Rien de tel qu'un bon scandale.
Le marketing sportif est né,
et chez Nike, on se frotte les mains.
- Des gens se plaignaient auprès de Nike,
mais Phil Knight nous répétait :.
"Nous, on adore ce garçon si particulier.
Ne vous inquiétez pas."
C'était important pour eux d'avoir
le numéro un mondial ou presque.
Ça leur faisait de la publicité.
Quand un journal racontait que John
s'étaient disputés avec un arbitre,
et disait ensuite :
"Au fait, John a gagné 6-1, 6-3, 6-4."
tout le monde était content.
- Il a commencé à porter
ses premières paires en 78,
et il est toujours sous contrat chez Nike
actuellement au bout de 37 ans.
C'est une histoire extraordinaire.
Aujourd'hui, cette chaussure est depuis 37 ans
sur le marché parce que c'est la McEnroe.
Ce sont les plus grandes réussites marketing
du sport marketing dans le tennis,
Il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
une telle réussite ailleurs.
La Air Jordan dans le basket, oui, mais
la Stan Smith et la suprême courte,
c'est extraordinaire.
Mcenroe, emblème de Nike,
Connors qui butine d'un sponsor à l'autre,
sans oublier les matchs officiels
et certains tournois exhibitions,
où l'on se partage
jusqu'à 1 millionde dollars.
Entre Mac et Jimbo, la rivalité
est donc aussi financière.
- Ces types gagnaient énormément d'argent.
Comme Jimmy venait d'une famille moins
fortunée, c'était important pour lui,
de se sécuriser financièrement
et de gagner de l'argent.
Ça en faisait un héros,
l'Américain à succès, le millionnaire.
Avec ses avions privés, ses limousines.
Sexe, drogue et rock'n roll.
Je pense que ça peut faire aussi
perdre les pédales, tout ça.
Cette obsession de l'argent.
Et qui est meilleur que l'autre ?
John était considéré comme un grand,
un type qui gagnait beaucoup d'argent,
avec la moustache,
ce côté beau mec australien.
Jimmy faisait tout
pour rivaliser avec lui là dessus.
La bagarre sur le court et en dehors.
En 1980, John McEnroe
est numéro un mondial,
mais c'est aussi une immense star.
Bien au-delà des cours de tennis.
Ses professeurs de guitare ont pour
nom Eric Clapton, Eddie Van Halen,
Aerosmith, Santana ici en 1982.
Les plus grands noms du rock
gravitent autour de lui.
Cinq ans seulement
après la première rencontre,
et cette humiliation
dans les vestiaires de Wimbledon.
John, l'élève,
a rattrapé Jimbo le maître.
Très loin de la marionnette
ridicule qu'imaginait Connors.
Champion le jour, rockeur la nuit,
et personne n'y trouve rien à redire.
La génération Connors, McEnroe, Borg...
Sur un tournoi comme Monte-Carlo, on pouvait
les trouver en boîte de nuit entre 2 matchs.
Aujourd'hui, vous n'imaginez pas trouver
Federer, Nadal ou Djokovic,
dans une boîte de nuit pendant Roland-Garros.
Ce n'est pas possible.
Il leur est interdit de le faire pas pour le moral,
parce que physiquement, le sport est devenu
beaucoup plus dur et les adversaires plus forts.
Je pense que le sport lui-même a généré
le progrès du sport professionnel,
a généré des comportements
de plus en plus professionnels.
Et on est entré dans l'ère
des sports totalement professionnels.
Pour l'heure, la fièvre accompagne
donc les nuits comme les jours.
Sur le court, Mac le rocker,
n'a de cesse de contester.
Mcenroe devient le cauchemar des arbitres.
- Il n'y a pas de marque !
C'était pleine ligne !
Il n'y a pas de marque !
Mais Jacques ! Il n'y a pas de marque.
McEnroe faisait très rarement
confiance complète aux officiels,
que ce soit arbitre et juge arbitre.
Je dis ça sans aucune sévérité,
mais vous savez,
j'ai toujours dit à mes arbitres,
et j'en ai eu quelques milliers
sous mes ordres, si j'ose dire,
que si le premier quart d'heure
se passait bien,
tout allait bien se passer.
Surveillez votre premier quart d'heure.
En 1981, le quart de finale
de McEnroe à Roland-Garros,
reste pour Jacques Dorfmann
et son équipe d'arbitres,
l'un des souvenirs les plus
marquants de leur carrière.
D'entrée, il les met sous pression.
- Je veux que vous lui demandiez
combien de temps, je suis supposé jouer
dans ces conditions humides et pluvieuses.
J'aimerais une réponse à mon retour.
Demandez-lui maintenant !
Monsieur McEnroe demande combien de temps
il est supposé jouer sous cette pluie,
Il voudrait une réponse immédiate.
- Il était 17h30.
Le temps était médiocre et John pensait,
que les circonstances atmosphériques,
et l'état du terrain,
en particulier, le défavorisaient.
Donc, il ne voulait pas jouer.
Malgré tout, à cause du public,
qui aurait mis le feu au stade
si on n'avait pas programmé ce match.
Il a joué.
- C'est trempé !
Vous avez l'impression que c'est bon ?
- Il faut jouer.
- Pourquoi ?
- Vous devez jouer !
- Vous avez vu à quel point il pleut !
À plusieurs reprises, John m'a demandé
de descendre sur le court,
pour vérifier l'état du terrain.
En disant le terrain n'est pas jouable,
le terrain est glissant,
je vais tomber...
- Ce n'est pas grave s'il pleut,
le court est déjà trempé,
Monsieur Dorfmann.
Et naturellement, ses propos étaient
accompagnés de gestes,
Et les gens m'ont dit :
"Il a dû vous dire des choses terribles,
des choses très graves.
Il vous a peut-être même insulté."
- Il pleut déjà !
Vous attendez que ce soit une piscine ?
- Quand je jugerai que ce n'est
plus possible, je vous le dirai !
- Quand je me casserai une jambe
je vous le dirai aussi !
- Dire que c'est très aimable,
ce serait excessif.
Mais il lui est arrivé de dire
des choses bien pires.
Pendant toutes ces années,
les colères du petit génie,
intriguent le monde du tennis.
- Il n'a jamais eu de problème
avec l'autorité quand on était enfant.
C'était l'aîné de la famille.
Excellent à l'école.
Comportement impeccable.
Je revois mon père à table lui disant :
"John, il faut arrêter ça."
Je lui disais : "Arrête, tu es trop bon
pour ça. Laisse tomber, oublie."
Il ne faisait pas attention
à ce que je disais.
"Papa, je n'arrive pas à me contrôler.
Je bouillonne."
Il faut dire que l'atmosphère
était surchauffée.
- Il me prenait sous son bras
comme ça et il me disait :
"Papa, ça n'arrivera plus."
Le lendemain, au bout de 3 échanges,
il hurlait sur l'arbitre.
C'était frustrant pour moi,
mais c'était sa nature.
- Et il détestait perdre.
Forcément, ça a joué.
- Il faut revenir à ses années d'école
et à son sens de l'honneur.
Son prof principal à la Trinity School
de New York m'a dit :
"On n'a jamais eu de problème avec John
parce qu'il n'y avait pas d'officiels,
pas d'arbitres, pas de juges.
Et s'il y avait un doute, il donnait
toujours raison à ses adversaires.
Il leur donnait le point."
Et donc d'avoir tout d'un coup
quelqu'un en haut d'une chaise,
décidant si la balle
est dedans ou dehors,
quelqu'un qui ne jouait pas et avait un coup
d'oeil beaucoup moins précis que le sien,
Ça, ça le blessait profondément.
Êtes-vous en train de sous-entendre
que je réclame quelque chose,
que je ne mérite pas ?
C'est comme ça qu'il résonnait
et ça le rendait furieux.
C'était mettre en cause son honneur.
Je suis une personne honnête.
J'ai vu cette balle bonne.
Donc elle l'est.
Et si je pense qu'elle est dehors,
je vous le dirai.
Ce tempérament chez McEnroe va s'avérer
le fondement d'une redoutable stratégie.
Avoir fait tomber Jimbo de sa place
de numéro un mondial ne suffit pas,
il convoite aussi son statut de rebelle.
La place de bad boy est au cœur
de la rivalité,
et toutes les occasions sont bonnes.
McEnroe n'a jamais supporté
les perturbations et pour lui,
les gens qui tournent autour du court
comme les photographes, les caméramans,
les preneurs de son, tous ces gens là,
sont des perturbateurs
et l'empêchent de jouer.
- Ta g**** !
- Quand il n'a pas réussi
à s'en prendre à un arbitre,
il va s'en prendre à un micro,
à un photographe...
Surtout quand on prend des photos
quand il fait son lancé,
ça l'insupporte.
Ça fait du bruit quand
on prend les photos alors,
il allait voir,
tous les photographes,
et là, c'était devenu ses ennemis.
Plus d'une fois d'ailleurs,
il a tapé dans les appareils photos.
Ou alors en faisant semblant,
tout le monde avait peur.
Ou alors dans les micros pour
qu'on n'entende pas à la télévision,
ce qu'il pouvait raconter.
Il s'en prenait
à tout le monde, à la foule,
et puis souvent c'était à l'arbitre.
Mais il s'est rendu compte
aussi que cette manière de faire,
pouvait déstabiliser l'adversaire.
Et donc c'était toujours
dans des moments assez critiques,
qu'il faisait son cirque.
Connors va expliquer à l'arbitre
qu'il ne doit pas aider le juge de Ligne,
à retrouver la trace d'une balle.
Connors, lui, s'adapte.
Dépossédé de son rôle de teigneux,
il change de registre et use de plus
en plus de ce pouvoir comique.
Le public adore, l'adversaire déteste.
Chaque fois que vous loupiez
un coup facile, il disait :
"Allez, bouge-toi,
frappe la balle dans le tamis !
Il n'est pas foutu de frapper la balle !"
Moi, je n'entendais pas tout ça,
mais il disait : "Centre ta balle !"
Il rigolait. "Ce gamin n'est pas foutu
de centrer sa balle."
Il invectivait les juges de ligne,
s'ils annonçaient sa balle "faute".
Il faisait tout
pour vous mettre en colère.
- La différence entre Jimmy et John
et moi-même,
c'est que Jimmy et moi,
on faisait ça en rigolant.
John était très sérieux.
On avait l'impression
qu'il voulait tuer l'arbitre,
et tuer l'adversaire.
Nous, on le faisait en plaisantant
et c'est la grosse différence.
- Petit toucher de balle.
- Il a imité McEnroe !
Connors, c'était quelqu'un qui allait,
largement au-delà de la limite
de ce qu'on admettrait aujourd'hui.
Il essayait d'influencer
les juges, l'adversaire...
Il avait tout un jeu psychologique vis-à-vis
de l'adversaire pour le mettre en difficulté.
Il se moquait.
Quand il dominait, il avait
tendance à le chambrer sans arrêt.
Je ne pense pas qu'il n'ait
jamais rendu un point.
Je n'ai pas de souvenir, mais ce n'était
pas le genre à effacer une trace,
et à dire que c'était bon, ça,
c'était le boulot de l'arbitre.
Trichait-il ?
Pas forcément, mais il était toujours,
à la limite de ce qu'on pouvait
se permettre à cette époque là,
beaucoup plus qu'aujourd'hui.
Mcenroe est furieux,
Il a maquillé la marque, dit-il.
La manipulation à la limite de la triche.
À ce jeu là, Connors et McEnroe,
sont aussi experts l'un que l'autre.
John passe tellement
de temps à contester,
que l'adversaire supplie parfois
l'arbitre de laisser tomber.
- La balle est bonne.
Qu'est-ce que je fais ?
Il tombe à genoux.
"Je vous jure qu'elle est bonne !"
Une année où il jouait à Wimbledon,
il a mis plus de 5 minutes pour servir.
C'était dans un tie-break
au changement de côté.
Normalement, c'est instantané
et ça lui a pris cinq minutes,
et l'arbitre n'a rien dit.
Il avait la trouille que McEnroe
lui hurle dessus.
Il a mis cinq minutes
entre 2 points.
Ce n'était pas pour aller aux toilettes,
juste entre 2 points.
Est-ce que ça m'a mis en colère ?
Évidemment !
Je menais dans le tie-break
et il a fini par le gagner.
J'étais furieux.
C'est quelque chose
que je n'oublierai jamais.
C'est très injuste !
C'est de la triche !
Mais les arbitres
l'autorisait à tricher.
Appelez ça comme vous voulez,
c'est de la triche.
Mais d'une certaine façon,
c'était une de ses grandes forces.
En fond de cour ou même sur la chaise,
Beaucoup de juges sont encore
amateurs à l'époque.
Des gars du coin qu'on forme sur le tas.
Les fortes têtes
n'ont vraiment rien à craindre.
On ne pouvait rien faire.
Il n'y avait pas de sanction prévue.
Donc le joueur continuait,
hurlait ces insanités,
tenait sa raquette entre les jambes,
faisait des doigts d'honneur,
marmonnait des horreurs.
Étant sur le cours avec lui,
on entendait et on voyait tout ça.
En gros, nous on y allait
pour faire notre boulot d'arbitre,
et on se retrouvait
à faire du baby-sitting.
Le calvaire des arbitres
cessera finalement,
grâce à un vieux complice de Connors.
Illie Nastase poussera
le bouchon tellement loin,
que le code de conduite
sera totalement remis à plat.
Ce soir là, c'est justement John McEnroe qui
se dresse sur la route du Roumain à New York,
et tout dérape.
Aujourd'hui encore, j'ai du mal
à croire ce qui est arrivé.
J'avais 33 ans. John était très jeune.
Mon entraîneur, Roy Emerson,
m'avait expliqué comment agacer McEnroe.
Je n'avais aucune chance de le battre
à la régulière. Il était meilleur que moi.
Donc il fallait que je gruge.
Je prenais tout mon temps
entre les points.
J'ai même fait semblant
de dormir sur le court.
McEnroe envoie
des bras d'honneur au public.
Nastase, lui, demande qu'on appelle
la tour de contrôle,
pour détourner les avions
qui passent au-dessus du court.
L'arbitre craque, disqualifie Nastase,
et déclare McEnroe vainqueur.
La foule a commencé à jeter des canettes
de coca. La police est arrivée.
Le juge arbitre aussi.
Il m'a remis dans le jeu.
C'est le match le plus fou de ma vie.
La presse crie à la révolution.
Dans l'Équipe, Denis Lalanne
dénonce une nuit du 4 août.
"Un grand soir abolissant
la noblesse que le tennis,
promenait depuis plus d'un siècle.
Nous ne sommes plus
dans un tournoi du Grand Chelem,
mais chez les sous-développés du tennis,
chez les dingues."
C'est un scandale.
On considérait que c'était
la fin des temps,
et que si on continuait comme ça,
plus personne ne supporterait jamais
de regarder un match de tennis.
Les "sales gosses" au coin !
Le tollé est tel que les règles
du tennis vont être remise à plat.
Plus question de parler à l'arbitre.
Cela prendra des années,
mais ça ne calmera pas
pour autant le New-yorkais,
qui, dix ans plus tard, réussira
l'exploit d'être le tout premier joueur,
à se faire exclure
d'un tournoi du Grand Chelem.
Heureusement pour lui, le "sale gosse"
est aussi un bon Américain.
Qui, même à Paris, ne manque pas d'honorer
un symbole comme la navette spatiale.
Il comprend bien que le spectateur
français s'intéresse aussi à cela.
Mac, c'est donc aussi la Coupe Davis.
Tournoi par équipes nationales,
et différences majeures entre les 2.
Jimbo la fuit, lui la gagne.
Cinq fois, douze ans
sous le maillot américain.
41 victoire en simple
et l'amour du drapeau depuis le berceau.
- C'était important pour moi.
John et Patrick se souviennent
que je les couchais le soir,
en chantant l'hymne américain.
Les Américains apprécient
vraiment McEnroe,
ils défendent le pays, le drapeau.
Ils ne défendent pas seulement McEnroe.
Connors, lui, ne pouvait pas affronter ça.
Il ne comprenait pas
le concept même d'équipe.
L'idée de penser à quelqu'un d'autre,
c'était trop pour lui.
Donc il a été catastrophique
comme équipier de Coupe Davis.
La fois où on a mis les 2 dans l'équipe,
ça a été encore pire que tout.
C'est une finale de Coupe Davis en Suède.
C'est une horreur pour les Etats-Unis,
une honte pour le tennis américain,
puisqu'ils se sont fait
battre 3-0 par les Suédois,
mais en plus, ils se sont comportés
comme des petits joueurs.
Jimmy a complètement disjoncté. Il s'est mis
à secouer la chaise de l'arbitre.
Le lendemain matin,
il a fallu qu'il s'excuse,
et c'est parce que Jimmy s'est excusé
qu'ils n'ont pas été disqualifiés,
et qu'ils les ont laissé jouer.
Arthur Ashe était capitaine.
Il a dit à John : "C'est la Coupe Davis,
il faut que tu te calmes."
Et John lui a répondu : "Ta g****,
tu restes assis et tu ne me parles pas !"
C'était Arthur Ashe,
qui est quand même
quelqu'un de très humain.
Arthur n'a rien dit
et John a gagné son match.
Il a compris qu'il faut laisser
faire John à sa façon.
Ce duel de grandes gueules
totalement débridé,
passionne l'opinion américaine
des années 80 et la divise.
Jimbo ou John, le boxeur ou l'esthète,
le clown ou le colérique,
le gars de l'Illinois ou le New-yorkais ?
Même ceux qui n'aiment pas
le tennis ont leurs préférences.
Dans les grandes années de leur rivalité,
les gens se séparent en deux camps.
C'est vraiment très net.
C'est vrai que les New-Yorkais,
je peux vous le dire, sont 100% McEnroe.
Voilà, c'est leur garçon.
Il est à eux, il leur ressemble.
Dans l'Amérique plus profonde,
ça se divise évidemment
selon les régions,
selon les sensibilités.
Ce qu'on appelle
la classe ouvrière blanche,
sont davantage du côté de Connors.
Au fond, ce garçon, sans raffinement
mais tellement efficace,
ça leur plaît bien.
McEnroe à certains moments,
a pu faire honte à des Américains,
par son comportement emporté,
incontrôlé, incontrôlable.
Connors, ça a dû choquer ses débuts,
l'establishment,
mais après Connors, a incarné,
l'esprit combatif à l'américaine,
la conquête,
l'envie de gagner ces choses-là.
En plus, en épousant une playmate
à une certaine époque,
réalisé l'idéal de pas mal
d'américain de base.
Patti Connors,
les Américains l'ont adopté,
comme ils avaient déjà aimé
l'idylle avec Chris Evert.
Au milieu des années 80, McEnroe, lui,
épousera Hollywood, Tatum O'Neal,
l'actrice oscarisée.
Allant même jusqu'à inspirer Andy Warhol.
Les femmes, les artistes,
les politiques aussi
complètent le tableau.
Et là, c'est surtout le terrain
de jeu de John McEnroe.
- L'un et l'autre incarnent
des choses qui les dépassent,
qui ne sont pas forcément leurs
options personnelles profondes.
Connors avec son côté "Je suis
l'Amérique profonde, je suis comme ça.
Il faut me prendre comme ça."
Ça ressemble davantage à une forme
d'arrogance républicaine.
Et c'est vrai que McEnroe,
New-Yorkais, cultivé.
Même avec son langage de charretier,
il est plus proche en sensibilité
des démocrates de cette époque là.
Les gens plus réactionnaires auront
tendance à s'identifier davantage à Connors,
et les gens se sentant plus progressistes,
plus glamours d'une certaine manière,
ont davantage choisi McEnroe.
Cette Amérique partagée semble
finalement avoir tranché,
en faveur de Jimmy Connors.
Même à Flushing Meadows.
Plus ardent,
plus généreux avec le public.
John avait du génie, mais Jim était beau.
- Connors incarnait l'esprit de révolte
de New York contre l'autorité.
Bien mieux que McEnroe.
C'est une question de personnalité.
C'est assez étrange, mais Connors a vraiment
capté les vibrations de New York,
et le public de New York aussi.
Ce qui a d'autant plus agacé McEnroe.
John était jaloux de la façon
dont Connors, avec le temps,
avait compris comment fonctionnait le public.
John était à la fois admiratif et furieux,
que Jimmy mette le public dans
sa poche beaucoup mieux que lui.
Les amateurs de tennis voyez
que John faisait des choses,
que très peu de joueurs avaient fait.
Seulement beaucoup d'amis me disent :
"J'aimais regarder jouer ton frère,
mais j'étais pour Connors."
Avoir retourné le public est sans doute
la plus grande fierté de Jimmy Connors.
Dans ses derniers duels
avec McEnroe, il savoure,
surtout quand il gagne,
comme ici à Toulouse, à 37 ans.
- C'est un bonheur de jouer contre lui,
C'est un grand champion qui restera
sur le circuit longtemps...
Et, qui sait, deviendra mon ami.
- Félicitations Monsieur Connors,
c'était censé être un vieux monsieur,
Je reviendrai l'année prochaine
si Jimmy ne revient pas.
Mais Jimmy n'aura de cesse de revenir,
galvanisé par cette rivalité
avec son meilleur ennemi.
20 ans d'une carrière anormalement longue.
Connors sur tous les tableaux.
La gagne et l'humour.
Jusqu'à ce dernier grand récital
de 1991, à 39 ans,
une demi-finale à l'US Open
et à Roland-Garros,
ce troisième tour dantesque
contre Michael Chang,
qui l'emmène au cinquième set
avant de lâcher prise.
- À 19 h 25, plus personne n'a souri.
Jimmy Connors annonce
son abandon à l'arbitre.
- Je ne peux plus, je dois arrêter.
- Vous êtes sûr ?
- Oui, vous pouvez même prendre
ma raquette et aller jouer à ma place.
Moi, je ne peux plus jouer.
C'est terminé.
Moi j'appelle ça de l'élégance.
Cette élégance suprême de Jimmy Connors
contre Michael Chang,
entamant le cinquième set,
gagnant le premier point du cinquième set.
Et pour moi, c'est une très grande valeur,
ce point qu'il a gagné,
il peut dire qu'il a quitté
le tournoi cette année là,
en menant contre Michael Chang
et en tenant à marquer,
le premier point du cinquième set
et n'abandonnant qu'à ce moment là.
Moi, ça m'a profondément marqué
et je pense que le public aussi.
C'est un souvenir qu'il gardera
de Jimmy Connors.
L'ancien démon devenu héros.
Un salut au public, une ovation.
Mais dans le couloir, les caméras
saisissent sa véritable souffrance.
Celle qu'il cachait.
Jimmy et John posent la raquette
ensemble l'année suivante, en 1992,
mais pas la hache de guerre.
Sur les tournois seniors,
ils gardent le bon goût de se détester.
Fidèles à eux-mêmes, sur le court
mais aussi en dehors.
Il y a un symbole assez net,
McEnroe a ouvert une galerie d'art moderne.
Et Connors s'est s'allié avec des gens qui
investissaient dans des casinos flottants.
Je pense que là,
il y a une grosse différence.
Est-ce qu'il y a un problème,
monsieur l'agent ?
- Votre voiture est mal garée !
Mcenroe révèle aussi un humour
insoupçonné durant sa carrière.
Exploitant à fond son image de rebelle.
- C'est sur la ligne.
- Je suis désolé, elle est en dehors.
- Elle est dehors.
- Elle est dedans.
Comment pouvez-vous dire cela ?
- C'est clairement dedans.
- C'est dehors.
Vous n'êtes pas séireux !
Ce sens de l'autodérision,
le rend également incontournable
comme consultant télé.
Beaucoup plus que Connors
qui se concentre sur le golf,
en gérant la fortune accumulée
pendant sa carrière.
Les ennemis du court ne sont certainement
pas devenus des amis.
L'hypothèse d'une interview conjointe leur
fait toujours lever les yeux au ciel.
Mais l'un et l'autre le savent,
la rivalité leur a profité.
- John a toujours dit que Connors
l'avait rendu meilleur.
Parce qu'il jouait chaque point
comme si c'était le dernier.
John en parle souvent
à propos de Djokovic.
Qui a Nadal et Federer
face à lui depuis des années.
Jimmy avait à peu près
la même personnalité que John,
à peine différente, disons,
légèrement plus crue.
Quand vous êtes gamins, que vous vous
hissez jusqu'en demi-finale de Wimbledon,
vous faites ça au talent et vous avez le
sentiment que vous êtes le meilleur du monde.
Mais c'est évident que Connors, avec
l'intensité qu'il amenait sur le court,
a fait de John un meilleur compétiteur.
Et lui a fait comprendre :
"Ok. Voilà ce vers quoi je dois aller."
L'amérique n'a jamais retrouvé cette
authenticité dans une rivalité tennistique.
20 ans après Mac et Jimbo
n'ont pas d'héritiers.
L'héritage, pourtant, est inestimable.
Et laisse beaucoup de nostalgiques.
Maintenant le tennis
est un petit peu aseptisé,
Nombreux sont les gens qui me disent :
"Je regrette Nastase, McEnroe, Connors..."
Et beaucoup de gens se disaient :
"Est-ce qu'un de ces bad boy,
va peut-être secouer la chaise d'arbitre
et le faire descendre.
C'est sûr que maintenant
ça n'a plus de chance de se produire.